salut à tous c'est pêcheur de trésor
non'est
FA est encore bord du canal pour la
pêche et on aér quelque chose récupérer
pouri c'est un sac à
main
dommage qu'on peut trouver on a déjà
fait endroit il environ un an
l' c'est très très V quel
choseord
bu je que c'est coffre
mais tu vas
arri regarde comme un coffre un portable
ouais portable cassé portable cassé
enfin ça c'est les téléphones de dealer
ou de
criminel oh une boîte une caisse ouais
une
caisse une caisse d'argent ouais ah elle
est ouverte malheureusement on va
regarder quand même ah dommage dommage
non aprs il y a peut-être les pièces en
dessous ouais ok bon c'est bon signe he
ouis c'est bon signe en 5 minutes de
pêche
était tellement sous la vas faut
vraiment pas hésiter à creuser ouais
excement tu mou avec la perche
oui ouais mais là pour aller
là-dedans compliqué oh si il y avait un
truc qu'est-ce que c'est
ça magnetoscope audio Sonic stéréo
ouais énorme ah il y a peut-être une
cassette dedans ouais
attends je pense qu'il y a une cassette
à l'intérieur bon ben ça
c'est pas trop de notre génération mais
on connaît quand même mais il a pere
petit lecteur de
cassette bon vas-y je vais je vais
continuer à pêcher allément mais je je
vous l'ouvrirai et on va regarder s'il y
a une cassette à l'intérieur ça peut
être très drôle ça peut être très drôle
ça c'est des chose qu'on avait loupé
hein parce que celle-là elle est dans
l'eau depuis longtemps oui mais par
contre c'est dingue la la façon dont la
vase préserve la qualité des objets ah
oui parce que là le truc il est encore
neuf
hein il est comme neuf le lecteur
cassette
en vrai avec la perche tu te régales par
contre je pense même de là où on est tu
vois sans rentrer dedans ah oui les
bulles les bulles les
bulles vous êtes prêts ça vient je crois
ouis tu en penses quoi niveau poids un
cadre oua peut-être c'est incroyable de
voir toutes ces bulles
là quoi que il y a une partie
creuse fort tu veux en voie ton aant
aussi s'il te
plaît ça commence bien aujourd'hui
[Musique]
alors attends jeen j'essaie de l'envoyer
là là ouais
ok attends vas-y fa qu' en même
temps faud que je l'attrape non ouais il
est ouvert un peu à droite non
ah je suis bloqué contre lei c'est pas
grave ah ah
dessous il est un peu lourd quand même
il
est
pas c'est un coffre encast
encore lein comme ça faud Leder sur la
terre bien plate làbas
fond regarde gros
coffre
la route ça fait plaisir ça fait
plaisirè lanc à peu près une caisse un
coffre ça commence très bien
ok ça y est
je
regarder
ouverture il pris
tarif éta pas simple ça
avant
vas-y oh là là c'est un peu sale tout
ça on continuera à la maison avec le
tuyo ouais ouais c'est trop sale c'est
trop sale il fait chaud on verra rien là
va
étaler c un papier ou une pochette
pochette ou tu peux la rincer VO là
regarde non non du bois je vais rincer
ça mais je pense que c'est juste une
pochette plastique ouais c'est une
pochette peut-être pour mettre les les
permis les anciens formats tu
sa moto les gars vous des trucs ouais on
a fait un coffre fort et une caisse là
c'est Bour ouais c'est pas mal
hein
ah ah ah encore un téléphone
cassé c'est le fameux F2 là c'est
toujours les mêmes les téléphones les
moins chers là tac ah il y avait c'était
le F1 que tu avais fait toi et ça c'est
du calibre 12 mais c'est juste la
douille tu pêches àment et que tu vois
ça c'est que c'est bon signe allez on va
voir ce que
c'est je crois que j'ai un morceau qui
vient retrempe retrempe trop sale peur
de le perdre non
t'inquiète ah c'est un morceau de CAD je
crois non de CAD quoi que non peutêtre
pasantivol de voiture pere un
antivol
finalement c'était pas si cool non peut
mieux faire allez on va continuer
alors regarde ça c'est la technique
quand il a beaucoup de
vas j'ai reçu de l'eau
pardon il a bien mangé ouais ça va il a
mangé du saucisson du jambon du fromage
du pain parfait pâé repas complet ouais
il a tout goûté mais il donnait la pâ
Sass il m
pour de la bouffe
oui ce temp
noncheté quoi cassette là tu voulais IR
non c'est
Mor ah direct tu l'as sauvé calibre 12
et qui cette fois-ci est pleine pourant
c'est la même couleur que les autres
plus intéressant
regarde ah c'est pas la même longueur
c'est bon
signe du cuivre'estce que c'est ce
Mach vachement
ancien si vous savez en
commentairerique que je travaille depuis
longtemps il vient finalement il est pas
pas si lour
si on dirait un peu non on dira un peu
s'il ne faut pas pêcher non non ça
va j'ai
peur
gros il y a pas de raison ici non pas de
raison dans le
comm c'est un vieux
pot ça fait un moment qu' est là
commtin et voil la trou chef bien joué
faut vraiment y aller avec les les per
ah ouais là c'est trop on va les
commander hein ouais d'ailleurs oui si
vous voulez un aimant nous on utilise
les barbarien qui viennent de chez
Maison de la détection donc ça c'est les
plus puissants ils peuvent tirer jusqu'à
1600 kg et vous avez le code promo
pécheur de trésor qui vous offre au
moins 5 % sur toute la boutique que ce
soit sur les aimants ou les détecteurs
de
métaux et comme on disait avec Quentin
il v aussi des perches qui vous
permettent de de sonder les canaux un
petit peu comme celui-là jusque là-bas
ça
vient faut le travailler
salut s qu'il va venir fait une sacrée
quantité de Bull ton truc dis-moi qutin
je crois franchement c'est trop trop
bizarre il vient pas ch fois il vient
mais en fait ça ah oui un morceau un
bout de guidon non peut-être encore du
vélo je sais pas tellement sale
is encore des bouts de vélo he il est un
vélo qui a 30 ans qui est dans cet eau
là tu veux le donner de la ferraille on
a pas assez pour l'instant
ouais ça vaut cher aussi ah ah ah ah ah
ça y est ça y est ça y est ah ouais
c'est ça en fait il tombe en mi sous mon
aiment regarde il doit être dans l'eau
depuis très longtemps lui hein oh ça sa
sachz sachez ça ça fait plaisir alors
est-ce que le sachet était déjà là de
base oui oui c'est vraiment dans le
sachet là ouais vas-y doucement on pour
démunissant je crois
oui c'est bon ça fait plaisir ouais
calibre 12 ouais et des Bren ah oui ok
oui c'est pas du ouais pas de la Gren
chevtine Gren c'est des vraies munitions
ça ça fait des dégâts attention il y a
une voiture ok c'est c'est cool he sac
de munition ça fa long fait plisir ouais
c'est bon signe c'est bon signe trouail
bien joué merci il a combien une dizaine
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 et ben ils sont dans
serv 9 9 la 10è ils ont tiré avec la 10e
sympa sympa bien joué allez ça motive ça
du coup on
continue et oui une clé des clés de
voiture semblerait
Volkswagen dragon ça c'est un non ça
c'est un portail mais l'autre c'est
c'est voitures volwagen ouais pas mal le
fameux fil de pêche qui ah oui le plan
de pêche
ouais c'est déjà pas mal
attends qu'est-ce que tu as pêché de
beau bon je l'ai arraché
is faut les perches prochaine fois tenue
de plongé les perches ouais partie
2 vaccin contre les égoutiers aussi
ouais contre les égoutiers faut toujours
se méfier des égoutiers ça mort on est
un peu frustré par cet endroit parce
qu'on sent énormément d'objets qu'on
arrive pas à sortir avec nos aimants en
fait il y a environ ça d'épaisseur de de
vase plus d'algue donc l'idée c'est
qu'on va revenir sur une période telle
que l'hiver où il y aura déjà beaucoup
moins d'algu et surtout on va commander
des perches chez Maison de la détection
pour pouvoir sonder le sonder la vas
plus en profondeur et on va descendre
dans l'eau avec des combinaisons donc on
se dit à très vite chose promise chose
du nous voilà de retour avec Wim et Dani
qui sont venus spécialement de Hollande
pour nous aider donc voilà ce sont des
spécialistes des sticks vous l'avez
compris maintenant ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va aller dans l'eau on va
aller dans l'eau pourquoi on va aller
dans l'eau pour sortir tout ce qui est
coincé sous la vase on sait qu'il y a
énormément de choses vous l'avez vu dans
la dernière vidéo on était coincé sur
plein de trucs aujourd'hui on va venir
et on va les sortir et oui' aussi lancé
sa chaîne donc elle sera en description
n'hésitez pas à aller jeter un il vous
savez qu'il trouve beaucoup de Dinger au
Pays-Bas en
Belgique bien sûr il par en anglais sur
les vidéos donc tous ceux qui
comprennent l'anglais vous pouvez
regarder mais même si vous parlez pas
anglais vous pouvez voir les belles
découvertes
voilà il aura pas de problème c'est un
anglais assez
simple ok on envoie toujours le plus
grand
d'abord allez on va les
rejoindre quelque chose
yes vraiment beaucoup de V
premère trouvaille
catch c'est pas c'est cuivre
ok du cuivre
ah
Nice on est pas bien là alors rasta
comment ça va il se demande un peu ce
qu'on fait je
crois
Nice the nice thing you go in the water
you all the
stuff
OK
premier coffre
[Applaudissements]
fort
yeah
yeah the first sa South frs let's open
it
oh
ok boucle d'oreill pour
earings BC
d'oreill trouvé ou pas trouvé trouvé il
est
vide le million
Milon
le prochain sera le
bon
ok come
on super un coffre fort en 5 minutes
maintenant qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
retourner dans l'eau il y a nos perches
qui nous attendent rasta mets-toi à
l'ombre mets-toi
là allez ass
si c'est bien
ok on va checker les m on a une pièce
encore du
franc quelle année cette
fois-ci
le dernier Fran
ok bonjour
elle est
[Rires]
bonne AC
des un
[Musique]
Peet
here
need oh là
là i'm not
TI
ok well
done you want me to take the
toil C now
it later for
the
ta
jante
Peugeot
magnétique computer
laptop
HP
compa Nice Nice good out
the yeah
yeah
May
oui mais sur quelque chose de gros
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
un énorme cadre de moto
will
go I don't
know kind of heavy i
[Applaudissements]
jump OK
Nice
bra
wou celleel il fallait aller la
chercher on va continuer on a fait
qu'une toute petite partie on a déjà
plein de choses donc ça montre que même
après la pêche à toujours moyen de
trouver des
trucs que qui plonge il est un peu
fou
Nice
OK
kardashianx
[Rires]
ok je crois que j'ai quelque
chose
je sais pas ce que
c'est
ok une béquille de
scooter complètement fou il est
complètement
fou
[Rires]
are
toilette collection de
[Applaudissements]
toilettes
oț a
con
K
il y a peut-être un vélo à trouver ici
continue à chercher et là je pense avoir
quelque chose oui alors ça ça vient
encore du vélo ah j'ai le truc dans l'il
et calibre
12 elle est pleine donc bon signe
quelque chose làbas en
face c'est un petit
c'est des lentilles d'eau il paraî que
ça se mange jamais goûté dites-moi en
commentaire si vous avez déjà goûté les
lentilles
d'eau
W W c'est une
bouteille super
vieille la
couleur
noir
un
exhauste un petit pot
d'échappement CELI il est dans l' depuis
longtemps quelque chose
ça vient regardez toutes ces
bulles de
sécurité je vous dis il y a presque 1 m
de vas c'est incroyable j'ai jamais vu
j'ai jamais plongé dans un endroit avec
autant de V oh merde le
débile ma casquette dans
l'eau
abruti des e il a plein
d'eauz
pe
regardez
[Rires]
il trouvé la
mour une jante
ok ça fait toujours
plaisir dan a trouvé une nouvelle jante
j'ère qu'il y a pas trop de crocodile
ici d'ailleurs pas avant
avait que des jantes c'est bon pour le
poid cheilleur tant mieux ok une sorte
de latte
OK
on va essayer de trouver d'où ell
viennent les munitions là c'est la
deuxième plaine que je fais ici il a
sûrement un sac quelque part on va
continuer à travailler l'endroit si vous
voulez des perches en tout cas on les
retrouve sur le site de maison de la
détection donc c'est des perches de
marque magetard c'est la même marque que
les aimants et vous pouvez encore
rajouter une rallonge donc je peux vous
dire que ça fait le taf ce que j'ai fait
moi aujourd'hui c'est j'ai ajouté l'IM
Barbarian dessus mais on peut ajouter
n'importe quel ément et nos amis
hollandais le font avec le bist et avec
le terror donc ça se fait avec nimpor
c'est pas forcément utile d'avoir un
très puissant le but de la perche c'est
surtout de repérer les objets comme on
fait là j'ai quelque chose par
OK quelque chose
là-bas il quelque
chose
uneère une portière
entièreous en commentaire quel type de
voitureourendit des munition je beaucoup
de bout de calibre
12 comm ouvert sont trop vieilles sont
décomposé je vais continuer à zoner par
ici pour voir si je trouve d'autres
munitions petit coup de nettoyage desm
quand
même encore une ici et vous voyez il y a
de la poudre encore à l'intérieur ces
petits carrés là c'est la poudre
vive donc en fait tout ça c'est de la
poudre donc ça montre qu'elles ont pas
été euh elles ont pas été ouvertes elles
se sont juste décomposées avec le temps
il a trouvé une autre
portière
une autre ok quelque chose il a une
grosse portière et moi j'ai quelque
chose
[Rires]
aussi
si vous savez quel type véhicule ça peut
être on va la sortir on va vous montrer
mieux
mais
[Rires]
perf la
guitare
super
bag cl cl C cl
sa
ok yeah oh no not
maybe from car
car
la banquette arrière d'une voiture allez
nous on va faire une petite pause et on
reprend